I've been telling you for weeks and
months that as the pressure mounts
around Donald Trump he will become more
erratic and desperate and panicked and
the public-facing expression of this
panic is very likely to be tweets
endless tweets tons of tweets and we're
seeing it Donald Trump tweeted 82 times
on Saturday 82 times this makes his 10
tweet rants of six months ago seem
comparatively sane and sober now what is
triggering Trump impeachment including
the public impeachment inquiry hearings
starting tomorrow which will be
streaming live on our YouTube channel
the continued incompetence and
corruption of the people around Trump
including Rudy and Sean Hannity and many
others Trump realizing but tens of
millions of people want him out and they
want him out now Trump has been heavily
triggered and we're gonna look at a few
of those tweets shortly we're not going
to look at anywhere close to 82 but some
of the themes insult include insulting
House Intelligence Committee Chairman
Adam Schiff tweeting about him 11 times
Trump of course likes the claim
presidential harassment against himself
but tweeting 11 times about one
congressman it sort of sounds like
presidential harassment by the president
rather than of the president of the
whistleblower mentioned eleven times
some version of impeachment mentioned
nine times let's take a look at some of
trumps tweets a lot of them were
actually retweets of various Fox News
segments that Trump determined are
favorable to him sometimes they featured
Sean Hannity or others then there were
actual tweets that Donald Trump wrote
like for example quote but the witch
hunt continues after three years of
relentless attacks against the
Republican Party and me the do-nothing
Dems are losers for America one tweet
was filled with nicknames Trump saying
quote I recommend that nervous Nancy
Pelosi who backed up shifts ly shift the
Adam Schiff sleepy Joe Biden and the
whistleblower who miraculously
disappeared after I released the
transcript of the call the second
whistleblower who also disappeared and
the IG be part of the list another tweet
about the whistleblower and witch-hunt
saying quote whatever happened to the
so-called Informer to whistleblower
number one seems to have disappeared
after I released the capital-t
transcript of the call shouldn't he be
on the list to testify witch-hunt and
then of course the old stalwart
presidential harassment in all capital
letters which his followers just love
that one getting a hundred and twenty
five thousand likes this is a tiny
fraction of what Trump did just on
Saturday eighty two tweets how does he
have this much time I mean I guess he's
barely doing anything else and maybe
that's a good thing but aside from the
content of Donald Trump's tweets which
are particularly embarrassing and
erratic one would never imagine that a
president would have time to tweet 82
times in one day about anything if you
take the job seriously and you read
briefings and history and nonfiction and
do all of the things that many other
presidents have done you don't have time
for this stuff now as much as Barack
Obama read and researched by the way he
still made mistakes on the job so how
does Trump even possibly stand a chance
if he spends his days tweeting and of
course once again is the drug issue in
the background of this this type of
manic over-the-top behavior also common
among abusers of stimulants Donald Trump
according to some who were behind the
scenes on The Apprentice snorts adderall
he's been pictured with a stack of
sudafed in his desk at Trump Tower which
can also be crushed up and used in ways
similar to a Dalal adderall tweeting 82
times in a day is another sign that is
making people wonder about stimulant
abuse because it is not normal behavior
never mind by the way that he says he
only sleeps four hours per day and often
is tweeting in the middle of the night
more signs of stimulant use or maybe
better said abuse of stimulants make
sure you follow the david pakman show on
Instagram for continued coverage of
Trump's tweets at David Pakman show
while you're there I ask you humbly
follow me on Instagram as well at David
Pakman I do not pretend to be a medical
professional I do not pretend to be a
neurologist or a mental health
specialist but fortunately none of those
things are requirements to notice that
there is something very wrong with the
President of the United States and
there's a new report that says
Donald Trump is regularly stumbling
slurring and confused at the White House
now I'll be totally upfront this could
be drug abuse as we've covered this
could be early stage dementia this could
be some other form of cognitive decline
this could be the side effect of some
medication we've not been told Donald
Trump is on he's not been particularly
forthcoming about his health
circumstances this could be any number
of things but it's something that is
what is very clear and it keeps coming
up every time we hear from another White
House insider there's a new book called
a warning it's from the same anonymous
staff member who wrote that New York
Times op-ed last year we have some
viewers who are speculating about who it
might V might be we'll talk about that
in the voicemail segment today they
claim to be part of the resistance
inside the Trump administration and as
usual if merely 5% of what's alleged in
the book is true it's cause for
immediate alarm concern and action here
is a quote from the book / The
Washington Post I am not qualified to
diagnose the president's mental acuity
all I can tell you is that normal people
who spend any time with Donald Trump are
uncomfortable by what they witness he
stumbles slurs gets confused is easily
irritated and has trouble synthesizing
information not occasionally but with
regularity those who would claim
otherwise are lying to themselves or to
the country now there's a bunch of other
stuff in the book about Trump making fun
of women's physical appearance making
fun of people's weight Trump is you know
likely technically obese by the way he
still makes fun of other people's weight
the regular stunned nature of the people
around him but that stuff isn't even
really news or it pales and importance
really compared to this this is yet
another data point it's another set of
allegations pointing to what is in plain
sight yet somehow it's considered to be
in poor taste to talk about this
inappropriate to talk about this this is
the presidency this should go beyond
party unable to put together coherent
sentences being very up in one speech
with die
pupils and hours later being down like
he's coming down from uppers and
slurring and it's almost like he can't
get his tongue out of the way to speak
wanting to get to the oranges of an
investigation repeating that twice but
looking confused as if he recognizes
that what's coming out of his own mouth
doesn't make sense but seemingly unable
to make any sense walking out of Air
Force One facing his limousine but
starting to wander away until a staffer
can take him by the arm and bring him
back to the car something similar
happened when he was greeting the
Argentinean president at the g7 I
believe it was in Argentina and on and
on and on so I implore you put politics
aside for a moment this is an unfit
person to be president merely on the
basis of his cognitive state alone now
let me propose something that is now
floating around there is a point of view
that this is all staged and concocted
the idea is create a pretext for a
Reagan defense for Donald Trump if and
when criminal charges are brought
against him for who knows which list of
the litany of criminal acts that he
likely has committed as president you
know the thing about that that makes me
doubt it and I'm curious to see what you
think is that I don't believe Trump
thinks that that's going to happen and I
don't know that Trump is really putting
people around him in decision-making
situations who believe that that is
going to happen I just don't think Trump
has any idea what he's doing period the
motive is certainly there you might at
some point face criminal problems
because of your presidency let's start
to create a pretext that you're not
cognitively with it
I just don't think they believe Trump is
ever really going to face consequences
for what he's done and that's what makes
me think the idea that this is staged is
unlikely to be the right one I believe
what we are seeing is just reality
Donald Trump is barely being held
together by a thread and we've actually
got a specific example from this weekend
that I want to talk about next I want to
start today with something that is
really important and really worth doing
but I also need to
be careful because I know the emails I'm
going to get after we do this story
email Singh David how dare you
perpetuate anti-white racism on your
program what you're doing is only okay
because it's about white people if you
did the same segment about black people
it would be so inappropriate but racism
for some reason because of the left is
acceptable against whites but not
against anybody else no that is not what
this is about
last week I pointed out according to a
New York Times poll that among
uneducated white voters Donald Trump has
a massive lead but he loses educated
white voters he loses Hispanic voters he
loses black voters he loses biracial
voters Native American voters whatever
the numbers came from a New York Times
poll and they're very interesting Trump
crushing Biden Sanders and Warren among
white voters with no college education
but losing among white voters with
college losing among black voters losing
among Hispanic voters and others the
reason that we are separating educated
white voters and uneducated white voters
is because all of the other groups are
against Donald Trump both when they are
and are not educated so understand that
that's why the story is done this way
and it's an important story to do and
when I did the story last week I got all
sorts of comments defending these
principled uneducated voters they are
good people too and they're not
worthless because they don't have a
college education I agree
no one is worthless period that is
actually in line with my politics
regardless of education but the point is
what is it about being uneducated and
white that connects with voting for
Trump that's a real political question
when we discussed it last week one
person left the comment quote it's
almost like education opens your mind to
a larger worldview okay another said
anti-intellectualism is a major aspect
of the Republican Party they need people
to be uneducated in order to remain in
power and they know it these are not
racist comments now CNN did something
interesting over the weekend they
interviewed six white female voters
without college degrees some had voted
for Obama
before voting for Trump and others had
not but they all say we voted for
Democrats and Republicans in our lives
and this is really important when we
consider 2020 these voters white
uneducated voters in swing states are
going to be important in 2020
so check out whether these are people
you are comfortable with making
decisions about who leads our country
not because of the race because of what
they say okay the three women who voted
Obama in 2012 and then Trump 2016 are
asked how could you vote for both how
did you vote for Obama and then Trump
why and take a listen to some of the
answers okay so Marian explain how you
were able to vote for both I voted for
Trump because he was not a politician
you get tired of the same old same old
from Washington that and I really wanted
someone that would make big changes
President Trump he said he was going to
take care of us and he was gonna make
sure we had more money in our paychecks
and and help us out because you go to
work you work hard and you have nothing
and then there's people that don't even
work it that have more than I do
so this is why education matters they
fell for an empty talking point that has
no meaning whatsoever I'm not a
politician so vote for me that's not
objectively good right it was one of the
ways Trump tricked people you may not be
a politician but you're part of the
establishment status quo that funds
politicians and perpetuates the system
we have and you've used everything from
lying on your taxes and and credit bank
applications loan applications to hiring
undocumented immigrant labor in order to
line your pockets you're not better
because you're not a politician you're
just bad in a different way if you were
more educated you're less likely to fall
for a talking point like that this is
not about elitism it's about having gone
through a process where one learns
ideally to think things through for
themselves learns critical thinking you
aren't bad if you didn't go to college
you're not even dumb because you didn't
go to college and many people are able
to learn these things outside of college
but we're talking about tens of millions
of people here who are more likely to
fall for these empty talking points
let's continue
has your life economically financially
improved under president Jeong I have I
have a lot more my paycheck I I do have
more in my paycheck as well my stock
portfolio is doing great that's maybe
that's why I look at the economy
different I'm not where a lot of you are
financially I don't think I'm pretty
darn low income once again I have more
money in my paycheck this was one of the
biggest ruses of the Trump tax reform
and unless you know how to think about
it you get tricked like some of these
folks did the Trump tax plan included
changes to the withholding tables so
lots of people ended up with more money
in their paycheck week to week but a
smaller refund at the end of the year
but what matters is what was the total
tax that you paid I've given this
example before if I give you an extra
hundred dollars a month in your paycheck
but you get a refund when you file your
taxes that's smaller by $1,500 you had
an extra 1,200 in your pocket during the
year in your paychecks but then you lost
1,500 on your tax return you end up
three hundred dollars behind your
effective tax rate has gone up changing
withholding to give people more money
week to week even though in total they
might end up with less money again if
you were uneducated you're more likely
to be tricked by that this is not a
value judgment let's look at a little
bit more of this Donald Trump was
running and I said finally another
businessman and I got fired up as he
lived up to your expectations absolutely
I think he can he's doing just fine if
he says this is what I'm gonna do at
this time line he does it well he hasn't
built the wall that was one of his main
promises so I mean do you hold that
promise against him
no because isn't the whole wall part of
getting the money from Congress to and
isn't Congress stopping him from getting
the money first of all another
businessman like what model do we have
of successful presidents having been
businessman we don't this was another
issue I'm a good businessman so I'll be
a good president now think that through
question one is was Trump actually a
good businessman
it doesn't know I mean it's unclear when
you consider the bankruptcies the fact
that he started with millions from his
dad maybe he is maybe he isn't but the
real question is why does being a good
businessman if that's what you are make
you a good president another person who
fell for true bottom-of-the-barrel
meaningless talking points and then of
course she phrased she praises Trump for
doing what he says he would do she gets
an example of something he promised and
didn't do the wall will then the fault
is somebody else's so this sadly is much
more common than we would hope in
American politics now I'm sure these are
nice women I don't think anyone is a
worse person because they aren't
educated but there is no question that
certain types of base political
arguments work better are more effective
unless educated people and that's what
we're seeing here why do I want to teach
critical thinking starting in middle
school why should we teach civics and
philosophy and epistemology because if
you get that type of thinking ingrained
in people at an early age a lot of these
bamboozler politicians who count on
impossible promises that a more
sophisticated person would never fall
for they never get themselves elected
and it's really important to understand
also that not everybody who voted for
Trump has been tricked there are people
who voted for Trump because they knew
what it was that he was going to do and
it was good for them and they got it
okay so it's really important to
understand that this is only one part of
Donald Trump sawr electorate but it was
an important part and when you look at
the numbers these are the folks that are
overwhelmingly with Trump this is
important stuff this is important stuff
that relates to education it relates to
media it relates to issues it relates to
empathy I mean there's so many things
that relate to people falling for
talking points in the way that these
women have that's why it's important to
discuss and we're going to keep talking
about it for sure Donald Trump was
confronted with more brutal chance of
lock him up yesterday at a Veterans Day
Parade it has not been so good for
Donald Trump at public events recently
other than ones where his audience is
either hand-picked like at rallies or in
deeply parts of the country like in
Alabama over the weekend Trump went to
game
five of the major league baseball world
series in Washington DC a couple of
weeks ago he was met by just relentless
booing and chants of lock him up last
week he went to a UFC fight in New York
City also met with relentless booing
then he went to a football game in
Alabama and actually got some cheers and
then yesterday spoke at a Veterans Day
Parade in New York City and it was ugly
the crowd filled with signs like impeach
Trump signs that say traitor criminal
lock him up and then of course the
chance of lock him up lock him up a
throwback by the I'm realizing that some
people may not know what lock him up
stems from this is a throwback to the
chance of lock her up referring to
Hillary Clinton over her emails how
quaint that seems now during the 2016
Republican National Convention you might
remember now indicted former Trump
national security adviser Michael Flynn
was involved in leading a chant of lock
her up and we saw many others during the
2016 presidential campaign this is
Trump's hometown New York City and he's
hated every public appearance is
becoming one of these please clap
moments for Donald Trump and let's be
really honest about the true
incongruence of Trump speaking at a
Veterans Day Parade I am hard pressed to
think of a president less supportive of
our veterans than Donald Trump
he said he'd fix the VA in veteran's
health care he's not done it he's
attacked gold star families and gone to
war with the family of of deceased
military captain kazeer Khan he attacked
former prisoner of war late Senator John
McCain he said that avoiding sexually
transmitted diseases from women he slept
with was quote his own personal Vietnam
after getting a bogus doctor's note to
avoid going to the real Vietnam which by
the way I would have done the exact same
thing that was a completely pointless
and terrible military engagement that's
actually not what's at issue here Trump
wanted to use the military for his own
political gain by having them go guard
the border with Mexico during a
completely fabricated immigrant caravan
crisis which by the way who whatever
happen to that it's no longer
politically useful so it's simply not
being mentioned but expect that it might
experience a resurgence as we get closer
and closer to the November of 2020
election he claimed to be donating money
to veterans charities got the public
relations benefit of those donations but
then never actually gave the money aside
from the fact that crowds are
increasingly hostile to Donald Trump the
guy has no business whatsoever speaking
at a Veterans Day Parade I can't think
of and I'm open to hearing from you
is there any other president that has
been more hostile to the military and
veteran community I can't think of one
at least not recently
we have major major news to discuss
today Prince Harry and Megan have
announced where they will be vacationing
at the end of the year no obviously not
don't worry this is still the David
Pakman show there's a ton to say about
the real news which is we had our first
full day of Donald Trump impeachment
inquiry hearings and on the one hand
there is a lot to say and then on the
other hand there there isn't that much
to say in a sense I'll explain what I
mean by that the high light or the low
light depending on your proclivity was
that Donald Trump had an absolute and
total breakdown on Twitter as basically
everything that has been asserted so far
about the Trump Ukraine Fiasco was
corroborated with some new allegations
and assertions made which we will get to
a little bit later on in the program a
Donald Trump spending the entirety of
the just hour after hour after hour
impeachment hearings I think running
about 6 hours in total tweeting Trump
tweeting a total of by my count 26 times
during the impeachment hearings clearly
panicked and clearly erratic and clearly
furious but at the same time clearly not
understanding the content of the
impeachment inquiry hearings which we
will also talk about because if I were
to top-level it for you if someone
watched nothing of the hearings
yesterday and I had seven seconds to
tell them what happened
I would say everything that has been
asserted so far was corroborated and
even worse
allegations were made or even more
incriminating things were were said and
and that is of course what we gleaned
from the best recollection of the two
witnesses what we've heard so far from
the whistleblower and from Lieutenant
Colonel Alexander VIN Minh and from
Gordon Sunland and the whole host of
them was corroborated so let's refresh
and we'll get to Donald Trump's tweets
yesterday was day one of the Trump
impeachment inquiry hearings tomorrow
Friday will be day two during which we
will hear from Murray
Jovanovic yesterday we heard testimony
from William Taylor the former US
ambassador to Ukraine and George Kent
the top envoy to Ukraine now the thing
about the hearings was that they were
long and they were slow and they were
detailed and they were by the standards
of 2019 low attention span dopamine hit
media culture they were boring and they
were complicated everything that causes
Donald Trump and his followers to think
that nothing happened here it's a
nothing burger it was nonsense
it was old guys talking in circles about
nothing but if you paid attention you
would have noticed that the questions
from Democrats who were actually trying
to learn something were answered with
clear corroborations of the story as
it's been told thus far there was
context there was history there were all
of these things that don't make great
clips for five o'clock and 11 o'clock
news but the quid-pro-quo the
expectations from Trump of Ukraine the
military aid so on and so forth all
corroborated thanks to the questioning
of Democrats along with some
grandstanding as well I completely admit
now the Republican questions were almost
postmodern simply repeating vague
epistemological questions because they
could not actually put together a line
of questioning that pointed to anything
other than attempted bribery by Donald
Trump and the people around him can you
think of something and be wrong about
your opinion could you misinterpret the
intentions of someone else haven't
people been wrong before
about what they believed happened and as
I tweeted yesterday for a group that
claims to be against post-modernism and
relativism so ardently Republicans had
nothing to go to other than these
hypotheticals about how do we know what
we know can we know anything is anything
really knowable is true because they had
nothing else to understand Republican
questions at yesterday's impeachment
hearings you also had to understand a
lot of viral facebook nonsense because a
lot of the lines of questioning from
Republicans that focused on impugning
people's character character
assassination so on and so forth if you
were not up to speed on popularly shared
fake news articles and Facebook memes
and conspiracy theories you wouldn't
even understand where it was Republicans
were trying to go with their questions
yesterday and because of this of course
that is the defense that they are going
with they try to remind their low
information supporters that even though
the witnesses are being completely
consistent in their testimony and their
corroborating what's already been
alleged everyone might just be
misremembering or misinterpreting things
that is effectively the defense that
they tried to frame up it's not really a
defense but sadly Donald Trump fell for
it and that means Donald Trump's
followers will fall for it and think
that yesterday was merely just hey this
is people saying things that could be
wrong and that's it so then we get to
Donald Trump's tweets just completely
all over the place and again how does
the president have this much time to
tweet lots of retweets of lunatic
extremist content for example a video of
absolutely bonkers Republican Jim Jordan
asking questions with some bogus talking
points from Republicans on the Oversight
Committee a retweet of a big sign
claiming that Adam Schiff learned the
identity of the whistleblower 93 days
ago which is not only untrue it's also
irrelevant but again we we have time
we'll get to that a little bit later
retweeting a video obviously from Fox
News show Fox & Friends where extremist
Republican Kevin McCarthy McCarthy calls
this entire impeachment hearing process
a sham
what is Trump doing all day that he
sends out tweet
after tweet after tweet nearly 30 tweets
during a six-hour hearing and speaking
of fox news by the way because Fox News
was the subject matter of a lot of
Donald Trump's tweets and retweets Fox
News is now fully back on the Trump
bandwagon as far as yesterday's coverage
goes covering the impeachment hearings
by defending Trump by gaslighting
viewers with completely bogus side by
side biographical information about Adam
Schiff and William Taylor and we'll talk
about some of those bogus misleading
graphics that Fox News put up a little
bit later in the show
but first we need to deal with a bigger
picture issue in general with these
hearings and the Trump efficacious of
media here is something just genuinely
funny we've wondered for a while now
whether Fox News propagandist and friend
of Donald Trump's Sean Hannity was in
some way going to end up implicated in
the corruption and criminality of the
Trump administration now in the midst of
the Ukraine Fiasco Hannity's name is
starting to come up more and more
frequently and Hannity absolutely lost
it over this unfortunate reality so far
Hannity's name has been brought up by
two different people
first when mentioned by former ukrainian
ambassador murray ivanovitch or
yovanovich I'm not exactly I've heard a
pronounced both ways and then when State
Department deputy assistant secretary
George Kent who oversees Ukraine
mentioned Sean Hannity and the reason
Sean Hannity has been pulled into all of
this is that honest program
he said that ambassador yovanovich had
bad mouth Donald Trump now it's untrue
even though it did end up getting her
removed from her position Kent
under oath said quote I believe to the
best of my recollection the counselor
for the department Ulrich Breck
reached out and suggested to Sean
Hannity that if there was no proof of
the allegations that he should stop
covering them he then Jovanovic in her
own testimony described being told that
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo might
personally get in touch with Hannity and
tell him to stop saying these things
about her that they are not true and
this causes Hannity to just explode
on Twitter over the weekend starting
with number one more lies and fake news
I never ever spoke to secretary Pompeo
or anyone else at the State Department
about Ukraine I've never even heard the
names of the people mentioned from state
also I never talked to anyone in Ukraine
I don't know anybody there then going on
to tweet that number two here is a
warning capital W adopting that
grammatical sensibility of Donald Trump
you have all been told the truth again I
strongly advise all of you to stop lying
about me now of course these aren't lies
these are reports about testimony given
under oath by multiple people they may
be inaccurate you may say it's not true
what Kent and Jovanovic said under oath
but it is not a lie to report that this
is what was asserted lies are what
Hannah details on his show all the time
now what's the likely truth about all
this we know that there was a campaign
of character assassination against the
ambassador of Marie Ivanovitch we know
Rudy Giuliani seems to have led that
campaign we know Rudy Giuliani is
Trump's lawyer or at least was I guess
now nobody knows whether they are still
in that relationship or not and we know
that Hannity and Trump speak all the
time so let's play our Occam's razor
game what is more likely that two
different people perjured themselves
when they testified under oath in order
to incorrectly say something about Sean
Hannity or that Hannity who talks to
Trump regularly was simply doing the
same thing Rudy was doing because they
all decided let's go after ambassador
Murray Ivanovich you be the judge about
which requires the fewest assumptions
and if Hannity is claiming that others
are lying under oath bring in Sean
Hannity put him under oath
ask him the questions about exactly who
told which lies truly his name is coming
up way too often in connection to Donald
Trump's corruption to have no knowledge
or involvement in any of these efforts
is just coming up too frequently and
there's no reason that his name would be
coming up other than he is in some way
shape or form involved in this
same way that Rudy Guiliani has wrapped
up in all of this I would not be even
remotely surprised if Sean Hannity also
ended up with some sketchy role in this
entire fiasco and maybe at some point we
will find out let me know what you think
the extent of Hannity's knowledge and
involvement in Trump's corruption and
potential criminality is let me know on
Twitter at D Pakman or by leaving a
reply as a youtube comment if you are
watching on youtube we will take a quick
break and be back with much much more in
just a few very brief moments a
political ad campaign produced by a
left-wing PAC called American bridge and
the concept of this ad campaign they've
got a number of ads is trumpets who
admit it was a mistake to vote for
Donald Trump now I've said before as a
strategy for winning 2024 individual
activists like we are
I don't believe arguing with Trump is to
get them to vote for somebody else is a
good strategy for the left because
number one 62% of Trump is said they
would never question their support for
Donald Trump or reconsider it no matter
what Trump does even hypothetically so
at the get-go with two-thirds of
Trumpets you're simply wasting your
breath but also it takes a lot to
convince someone to change their mind
particularly when they're experiencing
the degree of cognitive dissonance that
so many Trump supporters are so a better
strategy for us at the individual level
is let's get people registered let's get
out the vote from people who already
don't like Trump but to the extent that
maybe disaffected is affected Trumpets
in the 38% who are not committed no
matter what to Donald Trump to the
extent that they might have their minds
changed I actually think that this is a
pretty clever ad campaign for a few
reasons which I'll tell you about in a
moment let's check out the one of these
ads first
my name is mark Graham and I lived in
Erie all my life basically it's a
blue-collar town started off large
manufacturing base lot a lot of water
shipping run running back in the days I
voted for Donald Trump in 2016 because I
thought he would make a change did he
make a change not for the good Donald
Trump only plays favorites for people
like himself not Erie Pennsylvania the
presidents of bullying because it's his
way or no way
he doesn't understand life around here
he thinks he's the smartest person ever
I don't think people believe that
I don't believe Donald Trump is on the
side of American people I think he's on
his own side if I could go back in time
I would tell myself to be aware of the
changes that President Trump is made
voting for Donald Trump in 2020 would be
like putting gasoline on a fire a bee
pack is responsible for the content of
this ad so of course the fact that ads
like these exist is terrible in the
sense that our system is broken
we need money out of politics I hate
PACs I hate all of this ancillary
spending I mean these these are well
produced ads this is not cheap the
airtime is not cheap I've said it a
million times but to the extent that for
the 2020 election this is the game this
is the game of politics in the United
States this is actually a pretty clever
there are a lot of Trumpets who won't
vote for someone else because they don't
want to admit to themselves that they
made a mistake they don't want to have
to face others with the fact that they
might abandon Donald Trump because
they're worried about what the reaction
might be ads like these with disaffected
Trump fists who say publicly I'm not
voting Trump again this can serve
effectively like a sort of permission
being granted two trumpets to abandon
Donald Trump because as groupthink might
call it that is effectively what many of
these trumpets are waiting for I am sort
of questioning my vote but unless I get
permission from the group to go
somewhere else in 2020 electoral I'm not
going to do it and when the margin of
victory for Trump ended up being about
77 78 thousand votes
in three key states including
Pennsylvania where that voter featured
in the ad is from a few ads like these
well produced and broadcast in those key
states could actually be the
difference-maker
this is a very interesting campaign and
it's also smart because it's focusing on
rural working-class voters that's a
group that in a sense propelled Donald
Trump to victory in 2016 in which at
least stereotypically Democrats don't do
as well with in many elections this
isn't so much going after Trump over
specific issues it's it's a general
economic critique but it's not going
after Trump for something specific that
he said it's not related to a Ukraine or
impeachment and that has been a
criticism some people wrote to me saying
these ads are too vague I actually think
that that's good this is a former
trumpet
phileas relatable when he says I made a
mistake I'm not voting for Trump and you
don't have to vote for Trump either
let's look at one other one this is
David Saburo it's from oh Claire
Wisconsin my name is David Silva robic
and they also call me solo I live just
south of Eau Claire Wisconsin I love the
community I love the scenery the one
thing I really like to do most is to go
out of the snowmobile water cross-cancel
national championship they race
snowmobiles across water it is amazing
they just go fast enough where they
don't sink but sometimes they do and
that's fun today I work for a plumbing
and heating company in 2016 I backed
Trump because he wasn't a politician and
that to me made him look kind of like me
or a lot of other people that want
things done in the country but it seemed
like now that he's in office he's right
in there with them being all crazy he
definitely thinks he's above the law
maybe that's because he's a businessman
if I could go back three years I would
say just think it over a little bit
harder in 2016 I bought it for president
Trump but not this time a B PAC is
responsible for the content
this ad these are the types of ads that
could really pull people who are unsure
the diehards it won't matter but you
don't need to convince the diehards it
was just 75,000 in three states take the
stigma out of changing your mind
changing your mind can be portrayed in
politics as flip-flopping negatively or
it can be doing the adult thing owning
your mistakes when you have more
information you come to a different
conclusion and doing the right thing
this time around is the way that I would
frame it and of course you know the
die-hard Trumpets will say the people
featured in these ads are fake former
Trumpets they were never for Trump all
of that stuff doesn't matter because 62%
of the trumpets are never going to
reconsider their support of Donald Trump
this is meant to appeal to the 38% of
Trumpets who are get a bull they're not
in the I'm withum no matter what camp
and it could make a difference in 2020 I
think that this is a good ad a good ad
campaign let me know what you think I
will remind you we are getting closer to
Thanksgiving 2019 we are going to be on
maybe Thanksgiving Day maybe Black
Friday I'm not sure yet we are going to
be doing our last major membership drive
promo of the year if you want to sign up
for a membership at an obscenely
discounted rate I mean it's it's it's so
low low low low priced that I can't even
say it because I don't even know why I
just can't that's the story I'm telling
you today anyway if you want to be
notified about just like the best
membership deal of the year on either
Thanksgiving Day or the day after get on
our newsletter at david pakman.com takes
a second to sign up you will be notified
on whichever day we decide to send it
out Thanksgiving maybe the day after
of this obscene membership special and I
will gladly welcome your support at that
hugely discounted rate get on our
newsletter at david pakman.com make sure
to follow me on twitter at D Pakman we
will take a quick break and come back
with much more right after this hey this
is really funny just because it once
again sort of pierces the false notion
that all these right-wingers and
trumpets want is to have transparency
and conversation and dialogue and
exploring our differences in a
respectful
a Donald Trump jr. was booed off stage
when it was announced that he would not
be taking questions during a book tour
event and there's kind of almost like a
recursive nature to the way in which
speech was curtailed it's very
interesting now the other element of
this is that the audience that did the
booing is a generally speaking Pro Trump
audience it was an audience at an event
organized by turning-points USA this is
the pro Trump group that sped spreads
pro Trump propaganda on college campuses
they have a couple of people at charlie
corks and Candis blonds and or Owens I
forgot and they're well known in the
circuit they love Trump Trump loves them
it's a whole scene right so Don Jr shows
up at UCLA for this book tour event to
promote his book I guess technically it
does count as a book even though the
writing can only be considered writing
in the most technical sense the audience
is told there will be no Q&A and they go
crazy
chanting Q&A and stuff like that and
ultimately shutting down the event and
Don jr. having to walk off the stage now
one more thing before we look at the
video and listen to the audio you will
hear a woman's voice pop up that is John
juniors new girlfriend as many of you
may know Don Jr is now dating kimberly
guilfoyle who is a former Fox News host
she's been traveling with Don to his
events and being part of them even
though it's only actually a bigger
distraction if you saw the appearance of
Don jr. on the view continually getting
into arguments with people while adding
nothing and then in would pop up
kimberly guilfoyle
talking over people in trying to
haphazardly defend Don jr. it all just
doesn't make any sense she's just
traveling around he he's traveling
around with the former Fox News host who
runs interference for him like it's all
just extraordinarily weird anyway she's
on stage as well let's check out the
first video
and that that is the problem and the
reason oftentimes it doesn't make sense
to do the Q&A is not because we're not
willing to talk about the questions cuz
we do to go for some sort of sound but
you have people spreading nonsense
to try to take over that room rude and
disruptive and discourteous
[Music]
so that they can hear you don't play by
the same rules let me tell you something
I bet you engage and go on online dating
because you're impressing no one here to
get a date in person
[Music]
many people have you catfish
[Applause]
so they are not pleased clearly with the
lack of a QA how patronizing is it for
kimberly guilfoyle to tell the students
that their parents wouldn't like their
behavior right now it is so funny in so
many ways and on the one hand it's
pathetic that he's not going to do a Q&A
right the whole thing with these TP USA
events is people get to ask questions
and sometimes the questions are
adversarial but sometimes the questions
are brown-nosing but whatever you're
doing questions and they're not going to
do it
so that's pathetic on the other hand
it's pathetic that anyone thinks Don jr.
has anything interesting to say that
they would be all broken up that there
isn't going to be a Q&A I mean it's
little the blind leading the blind and
in the the districtís sense and then the
video continues and Don says listen
we're ok with Q&A in principle but not
when it's bad faith or when people
derail it or whatever and then you'll
see them if you're watching cut to
another shot where the entire thing just
wraps early to resounding boos and they
just walk offstage on a college campus
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so TP USA is doing damage control
because when you hear the protests these
are not left-wing protesters right
these are right-wing nationalists
America Firsters pro-trump errs who want
their cue a so TP USA is framing it as
these are extremists this is just a wing
of the right
it is not representative of a mainstream
Trump supporter whatever guys I mean
have fun fighting about which contingent
of your movement was behind this but the
big takeaway is that as soon as they're
not in an in an absolute safe space
there immediately terrified and
triggered there was no big political
message here behind this protest of
these supposed extremists in the
audience this was some people who were
mad that they weren't going to get a
chance to ask Don jr. questions there's
no big political or philosophical
message in the dumb protest but notice
how when Trump senior Donald Trump the
president shows up at a sporting event
and people boo he looks visibly shocked
and he's grimacing when Don junior shows
up and people boo they just shut down
the event after having his girlfriend
lecture the crowd about how their
parents would be really displeased with
the way that they're behaving themselves
their protest doesn't even make sense
but it's delightful to see their own
side shut down their speech when all
they do is say that it's the left that
shuts down speech Don jr. has made a
speaking career and a book actually a
lot of the book is about this going
around saying the left shuts down
dialogue the left doesn't want their
ideas challenged the left doesn't want
discussion the Duff stuff doesn't wanna
have to answer the criticisms of their
ideas their followers go around saying
the same thing and what happens is that
Don Jr's has no questions of the crowd
shuts them down it's ironic in a sense
not that they have any ability to see
irony but what it really proves actually
is the bad faith net nature with which
all of these political memes become
perpetuated and they're actually
meaningless and we're gonna talk about
this on the Friday show there's a
question on the Friday show about sjw's
what
happened to sjw's the question is
nothing ever happened to sjws there were
just they became a popular target of the
right and they to the extent that they
reflect a particular wing of the left
they have existed for a long time and
continue to exist but the right has
moved on to other things at this point
in the same way it's this irony of
they've been talking for so long about
the left wants to shut down debate and
they don't want dialogue and whatever
and of course anecdotally you can find
instances of everything when it is the
right that is so heavily triggered by
disagreements by having to defend their
ideas by someone who says I'm not going
to take questions and then shutting them
down completely these people are
pathetic and they will never see the
irony because they like the president
seem to lack some I don't know if some
switch in their brain that allows them
to see irony and double standards